hello and welcome to see a plane bloomer
what is this portugal it's very it's
very small right i mean i-i know the
portuguese flag pit it's really slow i
really am and slow small yeah III is
designed to play III as the media 3 can
be hit by d5 bit of a strange idea but
okay okay be sure five him okay I can't
push you five here my like
ok it opens up the bishop I can go d 5
be 4 23 should be 34 a closed position
with more space still not sure about it
ok let's gain some space if he takes and
place 94 i have should be three i think
to keep things under control one ok it
doesn't want to I can go see 5 in this
kind of situation I'm not sure about
this let's do it it's an interesting try
and understand especially three yes sir
the problem or new well ok this is
definitely something that he can play
but is it particularly great sent
develop him Fisher 187 still looks find
him
there are possibilities to sometimes
just take on c6 and this Bishop is dead
it won't ever get out of it spawns pawn
chain them this is also why I didn't
want to take only for I want to if
possible preserve this opportunity and
now it's getting some issues that are
supporting the D file and the night only
form
and that move as possible so the eight
is going to play on live d8 akira isn't
that good a Teague and play with your
exes looking very strange maybe I can
caroline is 6 cm
and wow he's very close losing this
bishop very very close
look you 196 9f for takes on c5 takes on
e6 hmm
65 root T 196 wow it's really hard to
believe but maybe he can just about who
this this was also possible
yeah he survived this somehow not sure
what I did to roll there but I
definitely did do something wrong no
time 15 and blackest black is fine
Jim it's not very exciting but time wise
it could be interesting still one and a
half minute down
check
you
to check still nothing going on check yo
yo yo check wait stop check check check
check check check hey I got six seconds
I have six bloody seconds draw a third
it's a total row of course draw like
markets on time yeah okay okay so um
Kevin you should just use this position
nothing more nothing that's because this
pitch this ball is corner I keep saying
pawn on a seven it should just be dead
but I did not I did not kill it off
which is pretty bad so night if what
doesn't win but rook da twins hmm there
must be when this is just so ridiculous
looking on a seven and now 95 but why is
that
I don't get it okay just c7 hangs right
yeah c7 just hangs I mean I'm just
taking this this take cakes and that's
it rick is also terribly badly
coordinated yeah that simply couldn't
couldn't work I mean with this dead
bishop on a sound he played exactly
playing exactly into this idea let's say
where this Bishop is out of play never
did anything against it and yeah
especially after b6 yeah but okay check
this is check surprisingly not not so
great for what it still looks terrible
with the bishop 187 but it's attained by
a threat you know nice here takes you
can take with the bishop rue 57 and you
take and then this works because the
pawn can promote he gets too many porns
yeah this is of course oops totally
equal but I spend time trying to refute
his planned okay as it is final position
is of course also totally drawn yeah
okay anyway I should have just killed
dissolve earlier just spent far too much
time in my anyway okay well thanks for
watching